[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]
Якщо не маєш своєї ідентичності,
то ти є розгублена людина,
чи загублена людина,
бо ти нікого не являєш собою.
Культура є також дуже важлива для держави.
[Мюнхен,
Німеччина]
Це є Полісся посередині,
це є Львівщина...
[Надія Галабурда
Вишивальниця, колекціонерка, волонтерка]
Полтавщина, Київ...
Волинь... То є бойки...
Це є... Лемки!
[сміється]
Це є гуцули...
А це є також Гуцульщина.
І тут ще така картинка є —
бойківський пейзаж.
Після війни, коли капітуляція була, то всіх українців
і всіх людей, які були на примусових роботах,
скупчували в таборах,
у так званих [англійською] таборах для переміщених осіб.
Там тато, мама і мамин брат зустрілися
й так почали жити [разом].
Там були уроки, школи,
СУМ [Спілка української молоді] розвивався також.
Просто йшло громадське життя також.
Дуже багато людей виловлювали
і вивозили назад до Радянського Союзу.
Деякі добровільно їхали, деяких виловлювали...
Мама розповідала, що виловлювали людей
і примусово їх везли назад.
Але їх вивозили в Сибір або розстрілювали.
Я народилася в Бельгії.
Тато у квітні 1947 року підписав контракт чи договір,
щоб працювати [там] у копальні.
А мама приїхала до Бельгії також у 1947 році, але вже восени.
Вони там одразу включилися в громадське життя,
тобто СУМ, Жіноча організація...
Чекайте, то є баба, мамина мама.
Там ще є гарніша світлина, де вона у вишиванці, зараз-зараз, чекайте!
Це є баба у вишиванці і найстарша мамина сестра.
Наша мама в Жіночій організації
була культурним референтом, як ми казали.
Вона писала реферати і займалася святами чи роковинами.
І дуже займалася також традиційними речами
і зокрема вишивкою.
Тому від неї та іскра перейшла до нас —
любов до вишивки і до традиції.
Просто до українських традицій.
Найцінніша — це є борщівська сорочка, фактично.
Та не фактично, вона є!
Це був подарунок нашої сестри Марійки.
Вона його отримала...
Жінка їй обіцяла, коли вона стояла
перед Верховною Радою, у 2010 році,
вона їй пообіцяла: «Я вам подарую сорочку».
Вона приїхала до родичів в Австралію
і дійсно привезла ту сорочку.
Тільки вона трошки замала стала на сестру,
і так вона мені перейшла.
Вона є найціннішою, вона має понад 100 років.
Фактично не можна старі автентичні речі вдягати,
але коли ми в хорі співаємо перед німцями,
то ми стараємося передати те,
що нам цінне є також, і я вдягаю цю сорочку.
Бо, думаю, треба показати німцям,
що ми маємо багату українську культуру і традиції.
Люди підходять до нас і завжди питають,
чи то є російське, чи то румунське...
А тоді вже зачинається кипíт всередині!
І тому я думаю, що ми тут мусимо,
чи старе, чи нове, але ми мусимо показати тут,
що є нам цінне і якою багатою є наша українська культура.
Мюнхен завжди був політичним центром.
Були «бандерівці», були «мельниківці», були «двійкарі».
Наша Оля в 1984 році приїхала до Мюнхена,
і вона працювала в товаристві «Рідна школа».
І ми приїхали з мамою на відвідини,
чи я приїхала, не пригадую вже, як то було…
Пішла на Цеппелін-штрассе,
там до видавництва «Шлях Перемоги»,
вони видавали газету «Шлях Перемоги».
Ну, я підійшла до професора Васковича, і я йому кажу,
що я маю зацікавлення приїхати,
чи маєте роботу для мене.
Ну й він тоді сказав: «Добре, приїжджайте».
Так що я тоді приїхала роком пізніше,
це був березень 1985 року.
Це є Анна Ярославна. Це є Равенсбрюк.
І це є також Равенсбрюк.
А це... То ми танцюємо.
Це є пані Олеся Костюк,
тобто дружина Вадима Костюка,
нашого попереднього консула
Генерального консульства України.
Вони мають такий дипломатичний клуб жінок.
Тобто всі жінки різних дипломатів зустрічаються,
і кожна тоді показує з своєї країни там якісь чуда.
І вона попросила, власне, нас, щоб ми зробили
такі мод-шоу [покази] українських строїв.
Ну, ми всіх строїв не мали, але сорочки ми мали,
і тоді ми показували, я до кожного строю там щось розповідала.
То було одна така дуже важлива...
Родзинка, як то кажуть англійською.
У 1995 році мій кум, який тоді ще не був
моїм кумом, шлюб брав.
І хотів, щоб усі гості прийшли у вишивці.
Мама з татом якраз тоді поїхали в Україну, і я сказала:
«Мамо, як буде якась гарна сорочка,
то купи її».
І так з того ми просто почали.
Я ходжу по Мюнхену і кричу:
«Не викидайте ваші вишивки! Давайте мені!» [сміється]
Просто я зберігаю все,
а вони не всі цінять того також...
І деякі викидають речі,
які їхні мами вишивали.
Наприклад, у Бельгії два роки тому...
Мама нашої сусідки дуже багато вишивала.
І вона хотіла це все викинути.
Я кажу: «Ти що, ти здуріла, як ти можеш мамині речі викидати?»
[Сусідка відповідає:] «А, як ти приїдеш додому восени,
то прийди і забери».
Ну, я-то забрала цілу скриню, тим більше,
бо вони колись жили...
Ми горóд в горóд жили,
а їхня мати... Вони були з Полтавщини.
А їхня мама... Ну, ми своїх бабів і дідів
ніколи не бачили і не знали,
тільки десь у 1970-х роках бачили їх на світлинах.
І я назвала її маму «баба»,
і відтоді вона була баба — баба для нас.
Я собі думаю: вона так, наче моя рідна баба,
тому я її [вишивку] так взяла.
Просто шкода викидати.
І в Мюнхені також, як хтось, ну, помирає чи...
то я також кажу: «Не викидайте,
а як маєте викидати, то давайте мені».
У нас у хаті Україна була завжди на першому місці,
хоч ми й не народилися там,
але батьки були переконані,
що вони колись вернуться в Україну,
бо багато думали також тут, у Німеччині,
що вони може вернуться додому.
У нас, кажуть, все крутилося,
ми також говорили між собою українською.
Наприклад, ту я вишивала шість місяців.
Якщо ми беремося за роботу,
то це означає, що ми вечорами, на вихідних
і як ми додому їдемо до Бельгії,
то ми вишиваємо.
Ця мені дуже швидко пішла.
Наприклад, тут висить моя з Івано-Франківщини сорочка,
то я її з перервами десять років вишивала,
бо я її не любила.
Просто я розпочала її вишивати,
і щось воно мені [не пішло],
бо я червоний колір не люблю,
а тепер я її найбільше ношу.
Але дуже довго я її вишивала також.
А з Франківщини чому? Бо наша мама з Калуша.
Це Франківщина.
Люди кажуть, що як око паде на сорочку,
воно переважно паде на ту сорочку,
звідки походять батьки, тобто звідки рід походить.
Частина роду нашого є Франківщина, і тому з Франківщини.
Як то кажуть, шароварство? [сміється]
Це є дуже популярно, але це я ненавиджу,
бо вже як вдягаєш, то вдягаєш щось гарне,
конкретне, не китайський кітч.
На жаль, дуже багато такого кітчу
продають також в Україні, — це не є українське.
Я би то назвала зґвалтування української культури.
І то у всьому є, не тільки у вишивці,
а у всьому, що робиться, тримається.
Добре, можеш [робити] модерне, традиційне,
воно мусить бути також, бо треба йти [в ногу] з часом.
Але тримайся традиційного і не ґвалтуй те,
що вже тисячами років існує,
і має так далі існувати, бо воно є частинне,
і воно має зберігатися в такому стані,
як воно вийшло, чи живе, чи жило.
Я за два роки йду на пенсію.
[сміється]
І я вирішила собі, що як руки будуть,
що зможуть руки і пальці вишивати,
то я поставила собі таке завдання,
що я хочу ще з багатьох інших регіонів,
я хочу повишивати ще деякі речі:
просто, щоб були.
Мене питають: «То що ти будеш з тим робити?»
Я кажу: «Маю сина, сподіваюся, що він жінку таку буде мати,
яка також любить вишивати і любить то».
Ну, може, може, таке й буде!
[сміється]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Наталка Панченко, Катя Акварельна]
[Оператори
Анна Савчук, Павло Пашко, Сергій Коровайний ]
[Режисер
Микола Носок, Василь Гошовський]
[Інтерв'юерка
Ольга Войтович]
[Асистентки продюсера
Ксенія Фукс, Євгенія Лисак]
[Режисер монтажу
Дмитро Бартош]
[Субтитрувальниця
Юлія Леонтьєва]
[Коректорка
Леся Любченко]